the big economic news yesterday gdp down
for the second quarter in a row many of
the haters said david you will never
cover this because you have to defend
the joe biden economy to the death and
no guys i don't care i don't care about
defending joe biden i don't care about
democrats i'm not a democrat i'm just a
progressive i report to you what is not
what i would like to see or what someone
else says should be
uh gdp fell 0.9
in the second quarter of 2022. this is
the second straight decline and it is
being called a strong recession signal
there is a traditional
uh delineation of what is a recession
which is two consecutive quarters of
declining gdp
and indeed on an annualized basis gdp
fell 0.9
that's following a 1.6 decline in the
first quarter and this was worse than
the dow jones estimate of a gain of 0.3
percent the drop came from a broad swath
of factors including decreases in
inventories
residential and non-residential
investment and government spending now i
am terrible at this i believe humans are
terrible at this
predicting economic uh futures
i don't believe we are headed to a
recession i believe we are going to have
better inflation numbers in a couple of
weeks in mid august we're going to get
the july numbers i believe they're going
to look good
i think there will be a nice little uh
potentially a little little market rally
there i it's not actionable i'm not
doing anything i'm not buying selling
suggesting anyone this is just a
prediction that i'm making i think q3 is
going to end up being so so and q4 is
going to be better now that prediction
is worth what you paid for it which is
nothing okay but this is my guess and
i'm going to tell you a couple of
different things why first and foremost
there's this
conventional wisdom which is often not
that wise
uh or conventional which is the american
economy by definition has a recession
every six to seven years at the most
every ten we are overdue for a recession
i don't tend to believe that that is
hard and fast
it's possible but difficult to avoid
recessions but it requires a very
balanced
stimulation of supply and demand
and you can
in some theoretical sense do this via
fiscal stimulus low interest rates
preventing shocks like the 2008
financial crisis due to mortgage uh
products that were predatory and fed
into the feedback loop
now it never happens right like
historically it just hasn't happened so
we've had recessions on this regular
basis i don't actually believe we have
to have true recessions but we are
certainly going to have pullbacks and
we've been experiencing a pullback i am
right now partial to the idea that we're
getting to the end of the pullback
rather than only the beginning
if you look at the reasons why
the decrease in gdp took place
they're not the most concerning reasons
i'll give you an example reduction in
inventories why would their reduction in
inventories lowers gdp
why would you have a reduction in
inventories well one reason can be that
people are buying everything when people
are buying everything and consumer
demand is so strong
it's not exactly a negative sign that
inventories have declined even though it
lowers gdp that's just one example
second there has been reduced federal
government spending
this is usually what right-wingers want
when there is government spending the
right-wingers go we can't afford it
inflation it's bad it's all terrible
well you know what happens when the
government spends less the gdp goes down
that's another reason that gdp is down
but it's not actually representative of
private industry struggling and again
private industries is doing very well
um
residential fixed investment has
declined non-residential fixed
investment like these are not the gdp
decreasing factors that to me signal
that a recession is coming now again
i'm an idiot i don't know anything and i
think even the people who do know stuff
are terrible at making predictions but
it's just not feeling when you look at
demand is really high
inflation is coming down
we are close to full employment tons of
businesses have open jobs that they want
to hire for
this doesn't
feel oh my god am i saying feel do facts
care about my feelings no they don't
this doesn't feel like we're heading
into a recession and i don't think that
the next six months are going to be
disastrous now would i take that to the
bank hell no
what am i doing i'm doing the same thing
i always do i've got my asset allocation
it's you know
uh 15 cash
three percent crypto i've got my real
estate i've got my stocks and bonds and
i just invest monthly regardless of what
the market is doing i'm not i don't even
trust myself enough in these predictions
to go and make any changes to what i'm
doing but that's my take on this and i
know that
uh and by the way
i don't credit joe biden for any of it i
would be listen i was right there when
barack obama remember barack obama obama
when he was running for re-election
and mitt romney was running against him
i said
i think the economy will be good the
next four years whether it's romney or
obama it might be a little different but
it's basically going to be a strong
economy
and it just was going to be a strong
economy and if it was if it was romney
uh then i would have had to say the same
thing it was pretty strong
during a period under trump the economy
was fine i would even say i wasn't on
here saying oh trump's economy is
actually terrible it was fine job growth
slowed down a little bit than where it
was under obama but stock market was
good consumer confidence was good
inflation was low it i i don't i don't
do the political games that many people
do around this stuff and right now my
sense is
this is not the start of some massive
recession let's see uh you know four
months from now six months from now
seven eight months from now uh come back
and check with me and we'll see where we
are
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping